when your social media actions
eventually get to the point that they
start to threaten the bank balance of
the purse holders at the top
you will be removed
this is the way
[Music]
ah i just
did the jaws whedon video yesterday
you know there was a point in time where
i actually used to do a video a day
and i haven't done that for a while and
i'm not going to go back to it but i did
actually find myself wondering
how did i ever do that and then things
like this week happen i'm like oh
yeah right this is how i was more
focused on the topical stuff
not that i'm going to start doing that a
lot more not if i can help it
but there are some things that just i
see what's going on
i run it through my brain and my brain
goes um this bit
let's talk about this bit so
this is not going to be a celebration
or a condemnation of the firing of gina
carano
from the mandalorian and any involvement
in any future star wars
properties this is going to be a much
more
practical look first let us
recap what has been going on
gina carrano is a supporting character
in the first two seasons of the
mandalorian
she was introduced partway into season
one and was
fairly well liked she initially got into
a bit of hot water ahead of the release
of season two
when on her social media profile
on twitter she had something up that
came across
as mocking transgender people
she did a little bit of a walk back on
that
um after it started causing problems but
then
shortly after started getting in rows
and fights with the people who were
still coming at her so rather than
you know make uh an amendment and move
on she kind of kept bringing it back up
so that was the
first round of the calls to fire gina
chrono which i actually did a video on
at the time
now more recently
she in around november was posting
an awful lot of anti-mask material
again social media i mean all this is on
social media
so unlike say the video i did on joss
whedon which was about his behavior
on set this is about her behavior off
set
so a little bit of a different ball of
wax that's kind of why
i'm doing a video because it's a
different conversation so the straw that
broke the camel's back
on this the uh apparently third striking
you're out
was when she did a post comparing the
idea that people didn't like her
political opinions with the oppression
and
genocide of jewish people during the
holocaust
and generally when you start to use the
holocaust
as an analogy for what usa
celebrity who is saying things that not
everyone likes is going through
that's that's probably tone deaf enough
to get you booted off something
and uh and she is lucasfilm has
confirmed that she is no longer involved
with the project and will not be
employed by them
in future so
here's kind of what i want to talk about
it's the fact that
honestly what got her fired
ultimately wasn't really
the opinion she was holding she'll argue
otherwise the people who are
uh claiming that this is all part of
cancelled culture will claim otherwise
but honestly
it wasn't her views that got her fired
it was the fact that she kept generating
bad press over and over and over again
although to be fair if she had done that
that last one
first that might have done it like that
was a
um but ultimately
the issue is that she didn't do
what her own co-star
on the same show who was also a point of
contention when she was hired did
which was keep her head down i'm talking
about rosario dawson with that reference
now dawson had some issues because she
and other members of her family were in
uh civil litigation over accusations of
verbal physical and mental abuse of a
trans man
who knew them now at this point i should
have
checked i don't know if the entire case
has been dropped
dawson herself has been removed from the
lawsuit
and the main thing that she did now
granted this is a little bit different
than just expressing your opinion on
social media but
there was controversy around her when
she was fired what that video that i
mentioned earlier that i did i talked
about gina carano but
i also talked about rosario dawson at
the same time because people were
talking at the time i did that
about wanting them both fired rosario
dawson
never really spoke publicly about that
at any point she did the classic
hollywood
thing which is keep your head
down don't talk about the scandal
don't engage in any of the behavior that
you're already being scrutinized for
it's a very classic playbook and it
still works
interestingly enough one of the first
videos i ever did
talking about sort of the impact of
revelations about a creator's behavior
and how that reflected on my feelings
about
their work and things like that was
talking about channel awesome
which uh you know they made
i'm not gonna recap that whole thing but
there were a lot of things that came out
about the way that
that channel worked particularly in
regards to its affiliates
and how it treated them and when that
came out initially they made a statement
that just got them in hotter water
and then they realized they must have
learned their lesson because there was
even hints that they were preparing
further statements like a video or
something but they never released it and
they
never talked about it again and you know
what
channel awesome is doing fine they took
the hit they lost whatever viewers they
were gonna
lose when the thing initially came up
and then they lost a few more when they
made that bad statement and
rebuttal but after that
they stopped hemorrhaging viewers
because they stopped
bringing it up they stopped doing the
thing that was getting them in trouble
and that is ultimately the thing about
gina carano
it kept happening over
and over again and i will again
reiterate
i do not believe him for a heartbeat
that she was let go because of the
specific things she said
even now even with this last thing even
with lucasfilm saying it's because of
her abhorrent tweets
it's not because in a vacuum the people
at the top of
arts think we can't work with this
person because of what she believes
let's be real they think we can't work
with this person because they are
a liability they are going to hurt our
bottom line
it's not about an actual moral judgment
about what she says
it's about the impact and the ripple
effects of what she is saying
on the potential viewing audience
and at this point the calculus was
very simple for lucasfilm
what's going to be the outcry if we let
her go and there has been
some as would be expected
versus what will the outcry be if we
overlook this
again and you know what
the damage from letting her go they
figure that's going to be a lot less
than if we keep her
so she's gone much like i touched dawn
in the joss whedon video ultimately
these decisions
these actual and i'm not talking about
the people online
calling for firings and i'm not talking
about the people who are calling them
out
or articles being written or anything
like that i'm talking about the actual
choice to keep or fire these people
the folks making those decisions the
people at the top
the only calculus they have the only
thing they care about is
what one is better for us financially
this will always be the
calculus because if
she had just not kept
posting these things on social media
they weren't going to make her change
her opinion
they weren't going to start making her
think
differently they and as i said none of
this was about on-set
behavior they weren't going to make her
change how she worked
they just wanted her to stop bringing
negative attention
and because gina carano's biggest thing
that she's involved in
is the mandalorian every single time her
name came up in a negative way
the mandalorian was right there
mandalorian star causes twitter outrage
every time she did something their
product
that they're trying to sell gets stuck
in the headline
and makes them look bad and that
is why she's gone
the classic template the classic
playbook
for a celebrity getting
in hot water in the days before social
media
because i'm old enough to remember this
nonsense
was maybe an apology depending on what
it was
usually a stint in some kind of rehab
whether it be drug rehab
or emotional counseling or what have you
to get them
out of the public eye and away from
cameras for a couple of months
or however long it took and then come
back
and just don't do it again the problem
is
if your issue is social media posting
unless somebody takes your phone away
they can't get you out of the public eye
it's just going to keep happening in a
way that didn't
used to be the case it used to be
far easier for celebrities to just keep
their heads down
that's not to say that it's actually
should be hard work but
especially anyone who is building part
of their brand or has
any kind of personal uh dependence on
their
social media following or is reinforced
by that or what have you
it is going to be difficult for them to
not
do that anymore it's just
really funny to me that
she's now gone from the mandalorian and
no one is talking about rosario dawson
anymore and again like again to be fair
she was dropped off the lawsuit and she
stayed out of trouble since then
but it's that second thing that ensured
that she
would stay employed and she's getting a
spin-off
it's been reported that gina carano was
probably going to get a spin-off they
were considering it
it was going to be announced at the
december um
shareholders thing or whatever it was
where disney announced all kinds of star
wars and
marvel etc stuff but because she started
tweeting about anti-masking in november
they scrapped plans for that they didn't
fire her right off but they were
already limiting the uh
amount of ties there were going to be
between her and their product
and now three strikes and you're gone
and because i know some people are gonna
ask does this mean that i'm now going to
watch the mandalorian
uh the second season which i said i
wouldn't and i haven't
up to this point uh i don't know
i mean maybe the thing was i didn't love
the first season enough that
i was in a massive rush or i was feeling
all that pain that skipping the second
season first season was
fine i enjoyed it well enough i wasn't
dying for a second season to begin with
and i don't know
what my comfort level will be trying to
watch the second one
it'll probably be fine at some point but
it's not like i was
waiting oh god please fire her so i can
watch the show please fire her so i can
watch the show like
i'm so glad i i'm still gonna have to
watch her
and even though again trying to be fair
rosario dawson has stayed out of trouble
and there have not been further
incidents i'm still not sure if i'm
comfortable seeing her yet
i may be i may get there but
i'm not suddenly going to jump on the
show because the decision that i made
at the time to not watch the show wasn't
a
moral stance and i wasn't calling for a
boycott and i wasn't telling anyone else
what they should or shouldn't do
the reason i didn't want to watch it was
i personally didn't feel comfortable
i just had a gut level uh
factor and that's
less than it was now but it's not
completely gone
so i'll say what i said in that video
and i'll say what i said in the joss
whedon video
i'm not going to tell you what your
opinion should be on this
and i'm not going to tell you what you
should or shouldn't watch
or start or stop watching because
someone is or isn't involved with
something
i'm just going to tell you what i'm
planning to do at least
at present and give you the lay of the
land
but it's not my business to tell you
how to process these things
it is just really interesting to have
the contrast
back to back of joss whedon
for onset behavior gina carano for
offset behavior because honestly
she had a much better chance at bouncing
back from this all she had to do was
stop posting
him not only was there the pr
problem which is probably the bigger
part of why he was ultimately let go
but even if the pr hadn't gotten
when i say let go like he's not involved
in the hbo show he's doing anymore he's
probably not going to get hired to do
anything for a while
but there was some degree of a pr
element
there but there's also the issue with
when like
people weren't gonna wanna work with him
just because
the things coming out about him said
this is a toxic work environment
gina carano didn't have any of that
all she had to do was stop tweeting and
she didn't
hopefully i could be done with these
kinds of
topics for a little bit like
the the fact that i i had to do this two
days in a row back to back
is just
this is the world
oh my gosh so
gina chrono no longer involved in star
wars in any way shape or form what do
you think about it whatever your
thoughts are
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it i have a patreon
which is how i pay my bills and it's
what keeps this whole operation
up and running any amount you're able to
help
is greatly appreciated there are perks
at every tier including things like
early access to
certain videos and besides that i have
merch such as
beautiful valid loved link in the
description for these available in 16
different pride colors
but if you aren't up to spending money
there's the usual like share subscribe
all those help me out but you also don't
have to
because at the end of the day you are
the council i am only running the
meetings
and until next time i have spoken
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Applause]
hmm
[Music]
um